it didn't take Katy Perry and Orlando
Bloom nearly as long to get back
together last night the pair definitely
started some fireworks as they made
their red carpet debut
[Music]
laughing whispering and wait for it yup
PDA Katie was beaming posing beside her
man in Monte Carlo on their first red
carpet together today they hit a thens
for some sightseeing a source tells ET
that since reconciling they have been
spending every spare moment with each
other we're also told kaboom has been
working on their love after hitting a
bumpy rope they broke things off in the
spring of 2017 after a year of dating a
few months earlier things seem to be
okay at the UNICEF snowflake ball they
arrived separately but sat together
inside and that winter both were gushing
2et about each other she's amazing you
know I'm super proud of the work that
she does everyone's a teacher in a
relationship this year after spending
time together
overseas neither would confirm their
rekindled romance until Katie said this
to ET in April girls
one month later Katie left a naughty
comment on Orlando's Instagram post
promoting his play and later wrote oops
I meant to send that to you privately
well last night she doubled down making
her feelings public in this instant ory
from their hotel room our source says
they don't mind if anyone sees them
together anymore and their bond seems to
get stronger every day I love love in
Orlando's mother wants them to be
together she just loves herself some
Katy Perry
[Music]